and we will ban men
laughs
[Laughter]
foreign
is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and TV program The
David packman show
and I wanted to talk to David Patman he
is
David Patman is
[Music]
I gave it Pac-Man is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
emotional they are mentally off they
have no logic
and that's a baby man they go along with
homosexuality hold on Buddy
that's a lot that's a lot we win
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
Marathon but another bait about a dozen
because he's a logical thinking and
they're controlled by the darkness of
David Pac-Man
now
[Music]
David Pac-Man here's a baby
Patman is
[Music]
a baby girl
you're not here to communicate I really
appreciate you coming on I'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you we're not communicating you're
acting like because you're asking
bizarre questions
and you wasting my time I'm preaching at
home all right
goodbye
[Music]
I'm worried about my espresso machine
it's not a joke I'm worried about my
Lane
[Music]
yeah
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
the lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of the machine I'm
trying for getting rid of the machines
just pillows who did this attack who did
the Cyber attack so you have you know
the good Geeks and they patch it up and
they fix it and they put up better
protection virus protection but here's
what my attorney said he said um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline
to find a ride through it's really
incredible The Branding around that I
said no you're not giving my phone I
said arrest me I've done nothing really
so no we're not gonna arrest you I swear
you can anything you have here and you
can do it you can do okay
get rid of the machine I've tried from
getting rid of the machine I'm worried
about my pillow no no truth that's the
worst thing for you because your
cervical nerves in your neck I will send
you some pillows I'm worried about my
legs I'm trying for getting rid of the
machine okay turn them into prison bars
all right thanks Mike Take Care thank
you bye
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
Alex Jones is now very very upset with
me look at that that is a freaking
prefer right there who thinks he's
smarter than you think he's better than
you and he's gonna beat you
because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude India
something crazy
[Music]
not to be it's haters
what you asked for is now at the door
scratching so open the door prepare to
meet your destiny
[Music]
that is a freaking Predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you
oh
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets and shows
10 times 15 times
elephants and bathrooms
[Music]
elements of bathrooms what on Earth is
going on with Trump toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation a big massive dumps
[Music]
and bathrooms
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms
Gentlemen please technical problems
plaguing the stream right from the start
uh welcome everybody it is so good to
have all of you here including Donald
Trump and so many other people today is
day one of CPAC and I have to tell you
it's going so poorly that it seems there
are no streams and day one was canceled
it's beyond belief what is happening
with CPAC this year many of you may know
that the head of CPAC Matt schlapp was
accused of
I can't even believe I'm saying this he
was accused of pummeling an intern's
junk
that's I I mean I
you would think that I'm kidding but I'm
not there is a sexual assault
controversy wherein Matt schlapp the guy
who runs CPAC has been accused of
pummeling the junk these are the words
that they're using
and a lot of people have turned down
even going to CPAC this year now today
is day one CPAC as far as we knew was
happening right now but it's like it
doesn't exist we look at the agenda okay
this is the CPAC agenda CPAC back in
Washington DC they've got a full day of
stuff all sorts of speeches Mercedes
schlapp is scheduled to speak in about
an hour they were hearing from members
of Congress so all this stuff okay it's
CPAC today
you can't find a stream anywhere okay it
seems like everybody has bailed you look
at right side broadcasting they clearly
say March 1st 2023 that's today
and it's just like an endless loop you
just look at this you click on live and
this video just Loops this this is the
whole video this just Loops over and
over
and then they have an image that says
day one and then when you click here to
be taken to the rumble page
there's just nothing
the only thing they have live is a
republican press conference
and even that isn't happening live
okay you then go to
real America's voice and they just have
what seems to be some kind of looping
interview with Devin Nunes and then uh
what's his name Steve Bannon was
interviewing a guy with a handgun
the guy had the handgun not Steve Bannon
okay so that's what's going on here
Pelosi kept over everybody she's she's
gone she's still there but but she's at
least not not in charge
so there's nothing going on here we then
go over to the Newsmax
um YouTube channel and it's Greta Van
Susteren interviewing the biggest victim
in the world who was treated unfairly at
Martha's Vineyard Alan dershowitz
and there's no CPAC there's no CPAC
North CPAP there's nothing
it's literally not happening so I
genuinely can't tell you whether the
entire event has imploded so badly that
day one was canceled altogether
uh or whether it's so uh low end and and
just worthless that networks have opted
not to carry day one I genuinely have no
idea we have plenty of things to do
anyway so I'm glad that you're joining
me and it's just so great to be back and
we're going to be live tomorrow and the
next day and the next day we're going to
be doing all of it but just to have a
plan as we monitor for streams today I
did want to look at tomorrow's agenda
and we can agree together
um when we are going to go live the you
know the earlier part of the day I'm
filming the the podcast so John Kennedy
and Ted Cruz start a little afternoon it
seems that those would be good things to
cover JD Vance AKA JP Mandel will be
um speaking at in the one o'clock hour
who else to speak I mean this is a very
weak week schedule Devin Nunes is going
at 225
JP right JD Mandel Rick Scott speaking
around three then Mercedes schlapp will
be back
um who else are we even interested in
here I mean this is It's just so so bad
I think like the critical stuff I'd like
to cover are probably Mike Pompeo and
then Candace Owens
um so tomorrow night we it might be like
a later stream actually I we should at
least do Matt schlap and Chris Ruddy by
the way
this is ah
I don't even know if I'm supposed to say
this the CEO of Newsmax Chris Ruddy
damn am I supposed to say am I doing
something let me just think through if
I'm doing something wrong here
yeah you know what I don't care
the CEO of Newsmax has personally
reached out to me a couple times to say
he likes the David packman show now I'm
not saying that he's secretly a liberal
or anything like that that's not what
I'm saying all I'm saying is
he seems to he like he says he likes the
David packman show and it's pretty damn
interesting
um there's no NDA or anything he just
sent me some messages privately and said
you do a good job and I like what you do
sort of stuff
it's weird right I mean it's an
interesting thing given the weaponized
nature of uh of Newsmax but anyway I
think tomorrow I should plan to start
maybe at 4 30 or something like that so
we'll get the schlap Ruddy thing and
then Pompeo we'll hear from Senator Eric
Schmidt
um and then we we will hear from Candace
Owens but as far as today goes we're
going to continue monitoring right side
broadcasting seems not to be covering it
they've got an endless loop on their own
website
some very strange Loop is happening with
real America's voice and uh let's see if
I have anything else here
um
no that seems to be that seems to be the
vast majority of it so we're going to
look at a few other things now so
everybody knows The Strife that CPAC is
having conservative leader Matt schlapp
is accused of fondling a male campaign
staffer in Georgia
Herschel Walker campaign Aid says that
schlapp groped him without his consent
in October
wow
um
he reached in between my legs and
fondled me the former Walker staffer
told NBC news to my shame I didn't say
anything
uh went on to say
what else did they go on to say there
was this crazy thing about
okay slap drank Tito's vodka and began
intruding into my personal space at one
point schlatt bumped into the staffer's
gun while their legs touched now is
gonna euphemism here it's not right I
mean I think this is literally like the
staffer was was armed with a firearm is
it or is that what we are to understand
here it it's so insane
Sig Sauer
that sounds like to pronounce it uh are
you uncomfortable looking at me schlap
ass so it's like is schlap one of these
homophobic gay guys I just have no idea
I have no idea but it is insane and
meanwhile they're holding CPAC as if
nothing is going on although it seems
that they are having problems because
day one seems to be completely missing
here
um
then there are text messages that were
exchanged it's all crazy it's completely
insane
if he had made a polite pass at me and
left it at that only me Matt and God
would know about that yeah it's it's all
crazy because schlapp is one of these
guys who claims that
um you know gay people are a problem and
all of this stuff and I I guess he's gay
or bisexual I don't know
um it's all really really really wacky
let's look at a couple of super chats
that are coming in I don't want to
ignore people megwine says congrats to
you and the Miss is on the perfect
little one with love for your baby girl
thank you very much I appreciate that
Meg wine
um let me get to a couple other things
here
uh let's see
what we have oh I want to say that a big
thank you to Jason sickmeyer for gifting
a membership on my website I really do
appreciate that and a bunch of people
have dumped in memberships on Twitch who
I want to thank dirt nap tool moo
Charles Weiland Lo-Fi potato Donald
Trump Gatsby cat and rated Roy nug
Wrangler gifted five that's 12 and then
we've got one two three four five six
seven additional 7 and 12 is 19 19 plus
one nine and one zero carry the one one
plus one is two that puts us at twenty
and I really appreciate that and I will
open phone lines tonight if we get to a
hundred I shouldn't even mention this
but last night I did a sort of like end
the month with a bang uh on Tick Tock
and we had this Tick Tock only code Tick
Tock Feb it was supposed to expire at
midnight it didn't and so if anybody
wants to take advantage of that code you
would technically still be allowed to
although it's uh you you know pretty
pretty dicey a couple other super chats
coming in Kratos Orion says sir do you
believe the word weeb is a slur uh not
familiar enough with it to be able to
say so I wouldn't be able to say for
sure David do I need to worry about
Michael Pillow coming for my air fryer I
haven't even gotten an air fryer but I I
see all these great air fryer recipes so
I am looking very strongly at an air
fryer although my girlfriend is saying
just going to take up space on the
counter you turn our oven on convection
and you get the same thing
but the truth is it takes a lot longer
to heat up a convection oven so even if
it's quote the same thing you're not
going to cook salmon in 12 minutes
in a convection oven in the sense that
you first need to heat it up completely
which takes a while then maybe it'll be
12 12 minutes okay so I don't want to I
don't want to um stigmatize uh air
fryers but I also am not sure my
girlfriend will allow me to get one is
basically where we are as of right now
and it's a sad situation I'm not going
to lie about that
uh okay continuing on here
uh oh let me do you guys want to know
about a little uh little drama that's
going on a certain guy named Glenn
Greenwald and a woman named Brianna Joy
gray are now going after me because I
don't think that Marianne Williamson's
campaign for president is interesting do
you guys want to know about that or
should we skip the drama altogether
anybody want to weigh in on that
it is quite a pathetic scene that is
going on I have to tell you
people are interested
couple people say skip
people say go for it okay here's what's
going on
uh Marianne Williamson is running for
the Democratic nomination she's
challenging Joe Biden now if Joe Biden
runs there's not going to be a serious
primary there aren't going to be debates
and Marianne Williamson will accomplish
nothing okay there are people three
people wrote to me and said David
Marianne Williamson will push Biden left
no she won't because she won't even get
on a stage with Joe Biden if Biden
doesn't run and there's like a broad
primary she also has no chance okay but
fine whatever for me I look at Marianne
Williamson and I go okay does she have
any experience no
does she have any expertise
no does she have any
community that would allow her to get
things done if she somehow became
president
no it's sort of like you might go to
someone for Reiki which I don't I think
Reiki is nonsense but you might go to
someone for Reiki and they might want
Medicare for all
but that doesn't mean you make them
president and it doesn't mean that if
they become president they'll be able to
get Medicare for all done right yes
Marianne Williamson
has good views about climate change
but you can also go to an acupuncturist
who might have good views about climate
change it doesn't mean you make them the
president of the United States so Glenn
Greenwald
um responds to my clip about it where I
read some quotes from Marianne
Williamson and he says those quotes
aren't remotely kooky they're reflective
of someone engaging the vast mysteries
of Life via spirituality and
Transcendence but to utterly
conventional midwits serving as normalcy
enforcers David pakman show anything
beyond New York Times op-ed page drek
seems crazy
then uh Brianna Joy gray weighed in and
said Biden guy wants to vote for Biden
again this is why that part of the left
is dead
that part of the left
what the part that only ever is the one
that wins anything
and is the only one that gets
anything done
what which is the part that's not dead
that Brianna is referring to
so you know listen
um I defend Marianne Williamson's right
to run
I support her and anyone who wants to
run running this is the American way my
opinion is that she's not interesting my
opinion is she won't push Biden left my
opinion is I don't want someone with no
experience or expertise of any kind in
any way related to the way politics
Works being the nominee or president
that's not interesting to me
so sue me
so sue me okay so um listen you know
these are the there's a I don't know
about Brianna Joy gray I I'm not
familiar with her really
but Glenn Greenwald was one of the
tulses in 2020
and I'm seeing now that the tulses have
been completely humiliated because Tulsi
was sort of like this pseudo anti-wokist
anti-vaxx right libertarian populist
rhetoric word salad type person she was
never on the left the way some people
said she was kind of the the last true
leftist a lot of the tulses have been
humiliated because of what happened with
her and I'm seeing a little bit of the
tool sea energy shift and get behind
Marianne Williamson and I'll be quite
quite honest with all of you guys
it's all a complete and total joke
a complete and total joke so have at it
let's have a competition allow the
marketplace of ideas to get Marianne
Williamson uh as much support as she's
able to get I I defend her right to run
not interesting to me campaign going
nowhere uh have fun okay everybody have
fun thanks to towel C Sling Blade TR
napsta Jen here and robot laser party
for re-upping twitch Prime subscriptions
I very much appreciate that let's
continue because I have so many other
things to look at
uh with everybody here let's see where
we are
um okay let's go over here oh I'm gonna
talk about this tomorrow listen to this
this is one of the dumbest things I have
ever seen
oh I don't even know how do I even how
do I even explain this
there is some very old
sort of like
racist Theory
I guess I would call it
that sought to divide
the races into
mongoloids
caucasoids and negroids
okay
it's like been widely done away with and
it's all insanely pathetic but on
Newsmax they brought on this guy Vernon
Jones to talk about I don't even know
what and he tried talking about
mongoloids caucasoids and negroids
and listen to the way he says them like
even he doesn't seem to understand
just just listen to this okay what he
said yesterday he said I'm a what at
this church I'm a white boy but I'm not
stupid oh okay this is all about Joe
Biden saying I'm a white boy but I'm not
stupid it was a joke Joe Biden made I
don't know if it's funny or not I don't
really care listen to this Vernon I mean
yeah let me drop back for a second first
of all Jason my good friend uh being
Latino is no race there's only three
races monogor Conquest sword and negroid
okay do you hear that
monogourd
a sword
I'm a caucusword is what they've told me
uh but when I was a kid I I was a
different thing okay
um listen to that again okay he doesn't
even he's not even on board with the
right racist terminology drop back for a
second first of all Jason my good friend
uh being Latino is no race there's only
three races
sword
managord and a caucusord
completely disgusting conversation okay
this is what they're talking about on
Newsmax
a sword
uh also Brontosaurus
is one that I think should be should be
considered so uh let's just see how it
continued and negroid uh but liberals
create this whole new class or a new
race called liberals don't want to talk
about caca sword and they don't even
really want to talk about monogord
either you know if they're no race and
it is it is very clear he did say that
that Hispanics are more diverse in their
thinking than African-American not
diverse in where they from come from as
a matter of fact Spaniards have nothing
to do with Mexicans and they all speak
the same language but again liberals
created this race if you and made it
unique based on the Liberals invented
Kaka sword and monogord they invented it
out of whole cloth out of thin air you
speaking uh Hispanic I speak I'm sorry
Spanish yes do you speak Hispanic sir so
let's be clear about that too Crystal
Clear analysis by the way it just
pristine analysis combine stands in
front of a black college like Morehouse
and Spelman he says that the reason why
black businesses aren't as successful as
whites is because they don't have
lawyers and they don't have accountants
that is racist there is only one true
race we are all caucasaurus of Rex oh
God these people are insane insane
uh so that's a really powerful
discussion about the nuances of race as
you can imagine
um wow wow wow wow
um okay let's continue oh whoa hold on a
second thank you to S Prez for dumping
in
59 subscriptions 59 subscriptions
putting us at 84. I will open phone
lines at 100 and even though I'm not
supposed to tell you about it the coupon
code Tick Tock Feb which was supposed to
only be for last night's Tick Tock
stream is active it is a 70 plus percent
discount and we are deleting it at
midnight okay nug Wrangler dumping in
five more subscriptions putting us at
89. so uh listen folks this is the time
this is the time grab one of those Tick
Tock Feb uh memberships okay other a
super chats coming in
David sir should people make an effort
to unblock I have absolutely no idea
what that means to unblock what
should people make an effort to unblock
sure
yeah make the effort
uh I don't really know what it means but
I would say yeah make the effort let's
oh by the way speaking of eugenics this
is on the podcast today but I know not
everybody has necessarily checked it out
here's Candace Owens suggesting a sort
of eugenics breeding program for math
skills
interesting uh take a listen to this so
yes it is correct to say that these dogs
or bred to fight they treated them like
a dog they were bred to attack and they
were bred to kill over many many years
and the question of whether or not
breeding works of course it does the
question of whether or not Darwinism is
real of course it is you can breed for
Heights you can breed for intelligence
you can breed for stupid right if you
really want to right obviously this can
take place you can breach for
athleticism we see examples of this all
the time but it's important to note
folks this is uh this is like 1800s
Eugenics stuff huh that just because you
are bred in one way or the other does
not mean that you are locked into that
permanent state right so right now
genetics aren't Destiny uh the most
mathematically capable people in the
world are Korean does it mean that
Koreans are forever going to be the most
mathematically capable people in the
world exactly quite frankly the best
race at mathematics is a caucusord start
breeding Americans do better at math we
can start doing what they do over in
Korea
um or we could not and we can remain
probably the dumbest mathematical
country in the world and it's so funny
because she's so close where she's like
you know we should really do something
to be better at math right we should we
should fund education we should not try
to be crowbarring creationism into
science class we should not be wasting
time trying to ban books we shouldn't be
trying to eliminate the Department of
Education we should fund education you
don't need to breed anybody if you want
to improve math just start properly
funding education she's almost there
she's like we need something to improve
at math when children try to learn math
in school what what could we possibly
need Eugenics that's what we need no no
she's like 90 of the way there and then
completely uh jumps the shark and by the
way
uh actually you know what let's not I'm
stopping myself let's not even go in
that uh in that direction Bay photo with
a super chat says those dang liberal
Swords by the way what's the update on
the channel YouTube algorithm behaving
again
you know things have improved a little
bit since the the bottom out dump that
took place in early January on the
YouTube channel
um but it's not it's not like it's not
going great I guess I would say
um we're at one point uh 1.648 right now
just as a reminder make sure you're
subscribed to the channel it costs
nothing it is the most important signal
there is to YouTube to recommend our
content it's people subscribing and it's
free okay so make sure if you're
watching on YouTube and that subscribe
button is enabled right now make sure
that you press it so that it gets grayed
out and then that'll be a really great
thing one other note the Spanish channel
is live live live
uh many complaints about the fact that
I'm not doing all the videos guys I
can't do an English language show and
then streams and all this stuff and then
in addition to a Spanish language show
okay I can't do it but I did record a
very special message to everybody today
in Spanish uh just to uh just to try to
satisfy some of the demands
in Argentina
um
even in the Spanish messages people call
me sir and cry come on
a
you get the point so anyway I'm not
doing the dubbing myself I just don't
have the hours in the day I just can't
do it okay I just can't do it
um so it is what it is and the channel
is Live and it's a fantastic thing
lc007 has just re-upped a twitch Prime
subscription putting us at 90. we will
open phone lines tonight if we get to
100 it is day one of CPAC but it seems
like CPAC has been canceled
um let's just check in again is right
side broadcasting live it is not
it is right side broadcasting live on
this channel
it is not
real America's voice nope and the
Newsmax is selling emergency radios
apparently
uh yeah so we don't know what's
happening at CPAC we don't know if day
one has has been canceled due to
subterfuge of some kind it's really very
very unclear what is taking place there
but
um it's it's bizarre bizarre bizarre
bizarre stuff okay let's get back to a
couple other things Marjorie Taylor
green using an extreme extreme zoom lens
as you can see here
um describing the event that took place
oh God at a restaurant the other night
where she says she was attacked listen
to this
and this this woman and her adult son uh
finished their dinner and decided on the
way out they were going to ruin it for
everyone else
um and started calling you know I don't
know that everyone's dinner was ruined
because Marge was insulted I mean
terrible names and screaming uh at the
top of their lungs Fu Marjorie well you
know it's so disrespectful not only to
me but also to the restaurant there's
staff and and other patrons she doesn't
know that the restaurant staff might
have been disgusted with her presence
there they might have liked it that are
there haven't just having dinner but
this is who the left is Jesse in your
restaurant she previously said that
democrats should be harassed when they
go to restaurants interestingly enough
so a little bit of a little bit of a
hypocritical double standard there I
think we might say Austin says via Super
Chat day one of C Pac-Man yeah we will
be live so let's let's get back to the
agenda briefly so my thought is tomorrow
I will start with the Matt schlapp
speech then we'll hear from Mike Pompeo
Eric Schmidt and then Candace Owens is
going to speak then let's look at Friday
Friday I will probably start there are a
lot of lunatics early in the day but I'm
just not going to stream that early
Sebastian Gorka and Jack pesavich
Marjorie Taylor green is speaking at 10
A.M obviously the most important time of
the conference is Friday morning at 10
A.M that's when they're putting her
gates at 10 30 Guilfoyle
Trump Jr
interesting maybe I should stream the
morning I don't know that I'll have much
of an audience but there's actually a
lot of really crazy stuff in the morning
then in the evening
Ben Carson Wayne LaPierre he's a lunatic
this isn't even evening yet
Viana schlapp I don't know who that is
yeah I mean I think my instinct would be
to cover like Vivek ramaswamy Steve
Bannon Nigel farage maybe would be the
way to go on Friday
and then Saturday
Saturday I'm probably only gonna do the
Scrump speech oh but Tulsi is speaking
it'd be interesting to hear what the
last true liberal will say jair
bolsonaro dear God what an insane event
pillow will be speaking Bo bear
alistafanic
Monica Crowley and then scrumps at 5 25.
yeah I don't know I mean Saturday seems
to be kind of like the main day so maybe
that's the day to cover a whole bunch of
stuff uh we'll see I want to say thanks
to Eric Pearson and vaheed Kasai who
just signed up on my website using the
coupon code Tick Tock Feb now you might
be saying David we're not on Tick Tock
and February is over that's exact that's
exactly right but the code is still live
we're at 92 out of 100 I will open phone
lines if we get to 100 today which is a
critically critically important thing
all right we did Marjorie Taylor green
um we did Eugenics from Candace Owens we
did uh Kaka sword what was this oh we
did this one yep
uh oh Jamie Raskin video I did want to
play this for you let's take a look
oh God we've got an ad
yeah this website if you have an ad
blocker like the videos don't play okay
here we go station engulfing the globe
since 2020. that what the heck I'm
almost signing up for this thing did you
see that that was bizarre
oh don't tell me I'm getting another ad
oh God what a web this website is it
it's a mess it's a mess of a website
barely functioning
can engulfing the globe since 2020
that's serious Economic Policy what
President Biden and the Democrats are
engaged in and they have a silly little
symbolic messaging bill for a couple of
notations they didn't even want to
publish originally within the process of
offering executive orders meantime 30
seconds one more minute so Mr Raskin
thank you we created 12 million new jobs
in America how many million jobs do they
want to race over there
in their desperate sudden pursuit of
inflation you know they raised the debt
limit three times under Donald Trump now
they talk about the debt limit all the
time they raised it three times and they
contributed under Donald Trump 25 of all
the debt in the United States from
George Washington to Joe Biden 25 of the
debt under one president Donald Trump
and they did that and now they dare come
talk to us about inflation and the bill
that they Advance is one to have some
people pass some more paperwork around
come on give me a break give us
something better than the Running on
Empty initiative with no new ideas at
all we recommend a no vote what real
economic action requires is precisely
what President Biden is already doing
Jamie Raskin has been on absolute fire
lately it's actually pretty pretty
stunning stuff to see uh good for him
though absolutely good for him you
really like to see it Matt asks via
Super Chat David any more debates in the
pipeline nothing right now nothing right
now but I'll let you know if anything
comes up
um another Super Chat CPAC sounds like a
dystopian Carnival of insanity Obama
please and thank you keep it up David
absolutely
uh very very much appreciate that
um and then a big thank you to Sterling
Lana for gifting to Twitch subscriptions
which puts us at 100. let's open up some
phone lines folks let's do it uh I will
take some calls via Discord it seems
like CPAC day one has essentially been
canceled so let's do it go to the
Discord at davidpackman.com
oh this is our Discord music
uh
we'll call it live calls
[Music]
there we go okay
davidpackman.com
Discord join the waiting Lobby if you
would like to chat with me we will talk
to a few people and see what what is on
everybody's Minds uh thanks to hippie
chick for re-subscribing Via twitch
Prime I always appreciate that thanks to
Jacob gold Shoal Timothy Guff and Heath
wood for dumping in memberships using
the code Tick Tock Feb folk folks The
Tick Tock Feb code was supposed to
expire last night through a technical
issue it did not it expires tonight okay
70 off a membership at joinpakman.com if
you want to talk to me make sure to
request to speak on the Discord we're
going to go first first remember name
and town name in town if you want to get
on let's go to Jeff from Georgia Jeff
from Georgia welcome to the live stream
what's on your mind today sir
hey David how are you I'm doing well
awesome uh hey I had uh just a couple
questions really uh first uh you've
you've kind of yeah not to put a label
on it but
um describe yourself as a Social
Democrat yeah um I am not a socialist I
am you may be disappointed to hear
no no no that's fine okay
um what is what is the piece uh that is
missing for you
um to go over into that Democratic
Socialist part what what isn't quite
doing it for you well it's it's not oh
and people are telling me you're much
louder than I am let me just turn you
down a little bit
um
it's it's not that there's a piece that
isn't doing it for me it's like the
socialism piece isn't doing it I am not
behind
saying that as a matter of law
business ownership must be socialized
and so if you create a business
then you need to divide up ownership of
that business across employees that to
me is an authoritarian imposition so I'm
just I'm just not behind that uh I'm not
into socializing Industries with very
few exceptions like for example we
really should be taking the profit out
of Health Care and you know as I've
talked about
um I just don't I don't know why we
would do that I don't know how to
justify that
um yeah so it's less about like which
piece it just doesn't really make any
sense to me
gotcha yeah no fair enough I I just
never really heard you kind of like
articulate that that specific point
before but check out my YouTube channel
why I'm not a socialist where I go into
it in more detail beautiful I will come
with tears in my eyes
um and then the the second one uh are
you familiar with the uh spirit for net
branca
uh of course I'm Argentinian okay I I
wanted to make sure uh what is the
correct ratio in your eyes to the fernet
and Coke because I've heard listen he's
like here's the thing I know I know it's
like everybody's talking about 80 20 or
50 50 you know all these different
ratios I don't drink uh soda so I quite
frankly couldn't care less I have fernet
with a couple of ice cubes and I don't
care what ratio people dump into their
cups it makes absolutely no difference
to me I'm not taking a position on it
okay good very neutral position yeah I'm
basically like Switzerland on this issue
yes uh well awesome well big fan David
uh I have been trying to get on for a
while now but love what you do
um and yeah thanks for having me all
right Jeff from Georgia great to hear
from you let's go next to George from
Virginia George from Virginia welcome to
the live stream
George from Virginia welcome to the very
end stream yes I can
okay great
um so I wanted to I know that it's kind
of old
but I wanted to talk about the uh
Patrick David interview sure
um so
I wanted to give you like my opinion of
where I think it might have went wrong
and see what you're if you think I I'm
on to something okay
um so the first thing was
when you when he started talking about
Trump
did you notice how he got defensive yes
okay so I think what happened there was
he thought because you were criticizing
Trump voters that you might have been
like making a personal attack at him
because I assume he was a trump voter oh
yeah he's absolutely a trump voter um
it's possible that that's why he became
defensive I mean the truth is he is in
one of those categories he is a guy who
made a lot of money and he wants low
taxes and so he's not you know it's not
pejorative that he is in the category of
sort of like the low tax low business
regulation fiscal right-wingers that
like Trump you know
yeah definitely and the other part where
he kind of went off the rails was
when you brought up polling did you did
you notice how when you brought up
polling he got really defensive because
he was like
he's like oh yeah what you got a poll
for that do you remember when he did
that yes I do
um so I think what happened there was he
thought oh uh David's bringing up polls
and I have no knowledge of polls so now
he felt like maybe he was
out of his element and therefore he
couldn't defend himself it's absolutely
plausible yeah so those are just two my
big two uh observations I just wanted to
throw him at you and see how you felt
about it I think you're very much on to
something there George
okay well great David uh thanks for
taking my call all right thank you great
to hear from you a couple super chats uh
Guitar Hero says do you closely follow
International politics of any countries
I've been listening to a lot of James
O'Brien of Britain's LBC recently uh
mostly Argentina I would say
um us and Argentina are the two
countries I follow follow the closest
really I would say uh let's go next to
Herb from Long Island herb from Long
Island welcome to the program what's
going on today
hey David yeah uh I think this happened
last time but it's herb with a heart H
oh it's a herb okay thank you yeah herb
yeah you know it's interesting you uh
just as a quick aside you talk about the
historian and historian versus a
historian uh my father is actually a
English major Poet Laureate uh he
confirmed if it starts with a consonant
you should always use a
a and if it has a vowel sound you should
have an and so a historian I know the
rule of course I know the rule but this
is not about the rule this is about the
fact that I understand that if you just
say the word
historian that you start with a
consonant but in practice there's a lot
of sort of running it together in a way
where you might where an historian is
very common and even many historians say
it that way oh there's I've never heard
you know you're the first person I've
ever say heard that for historian at
least wow power and all the other things
sure but not historian all right yeah
yeah no it just never happened before
um I wanted to ask
um
so I know that the numbers have
increased for these like anti-trans
bills that have come out this year I
think more in two months than all of
last year correct
um where do you think that this will end
up in like a year's time do you think
that it's just all front loaded do you
think that this will keep up with this
trend of two months suddenly we'll have
like well in like 3 000 by the end of
the no I I think there's got to be a
breaking point I think it'll probably
slow down the reason you're seeing more
right now is because you have a lot of
new elected officials who were just
sworn in and so they're front loading a
lot of it I don't think you're going to
see the same rate of anti-trans bills
continue through the next year well we
can hope not but like it it just seems
uh overly aggressive uh to the point of
like almost comedy if it wasn't so
depressing if it wasn't so depressing
and dangerous it would be somewhat funny
but sadly you're right it's not
all right um yeah no there's just the
the historian thing I wanted to mention
and uh and uh uh the the question about
the the bills
um I know you got a bunch of people so
I'll let you move on all right herb with
a hard H from Long Island great to hear
from you let's go next to I don't know
how to pronounce this is it Amir from
Jordan it's just AMR which doesn't
doesn't it seems like there should be
another vowel in there somewhere I'm
sorry what was that
armor armor oh okay very interesting I'm
not familiar with the name is it is it a
uh is it etymologically related to Amir
no it's like it's it's a letter that
doesn't exist in English
yeah fascinating all right well welcome
welcome to the program I think you're
our first Jordanian caller that we've
ever had
all right last night I've been following
you for a while actually I appreciate it
um
okay I followed the your show for a long
while and all of the
most of the political commentators on
YouTube
and I was like coming from Miami-Dade
restaurant country there's a lot of
people especially in my
age group or thinking about immigrating
to the U.S
and like see with all my knowledge and
the things I watch I tell them no it's
not the best place to go interesting so
let's see what age group of people are
you talking about what I think seriously
like 30 around 30 okay and they're folks
who have expertise in What fields
uh mostly it and returns
I.T like attack space to some degree and
do they speak English as well as you do
uh most of them yes I mean listen I
don't know about it you know I I don't
know what the best places to go are if
one is looking to go somewhere but 30
year old 30 year olds with I.T skills
and English language skills equivalent
to yours have the potential to do quite
well in the United States
no my argument is like you're gonna be
happier
if not like more other restaurant
countries because eventually you're
gonna get old you're gonna need
a medical assistant you you need to be
sure that your kids cannot get a good
education yes and you need a stable
political system that's
it's gonna
be all right you're not wrong what
western country would you recommend to
some of these people you talk to
like if this be good English I I
recommend Australia or
the UK but UK is very hard like yeah for
people I don't know much about the
Australian immigration system is it is
it do you know is it difficult to to
move to Australia permanently
I think it's easier oh okay like for me
I didn't really search it but yeah I
have my own business and stable enough
for me not to want to immigrate
it's for you you feel like the economy
and your industry in Jordan are stable
enough that you're comfortable there
yeah right that's great but the the
question is where did the U.S go wrong
like I love the U.S I love the
Constitution and
that's a difficult question I mean check
out my interview with Noam Chomsky not
for anything he says but I I actually
lay out the uh I lay out I mean he said
interesting things but I lay out the
path of how I believe the US got to
where it is today uh but that is
certainly a question that exceeds the
scope of this this phone call that's for
sure
all right thank you all right armor from
Jordan great to hear from you I really
appreciate it
all right
um Super Chat says drink for net every
time they say woke during CPAC yeah
you'll that I don't recommend that
you'll end up with alcohol poisoning
thanks to Landon schifflett for signing
up on my website with the coupon code
Tick Tock Feb Tick Tock Feb puts you uh
put it puts us at 105 for the day which
is fantastic CPAC day one I guess seems
canceled there are literally no streams
so we're taking some phone calls and
then tomorrow we will have CPAC day two
which I guess kind of becomes day one
Sullivan from Phoenix Arizona welcome if
you want to talk to me go to
davidpackman.com Discord and join the
waiting Lobby we are taking the calls
via Discord uh Sullivan from Phoenix
Arizona
yes I can
hello so
um what I was thinking about was
implementation of Medicare for all so
the
so I like the idea uh but the problem I
see is if we just give everyone uh
Medicare we haven't guaranteed access
for like those in rural communities so I
think maybe we should what would be
would it be economically feasible to go
further and like not only insure
everyone but also make sure that
everyone has a provider in their area
yeah that's that's already an issue
quite frankly there there are places
where that's an issue
um and there's already a shortage in
many Specialties I mean primary care
doctors there's a shortage dermatologist
there's a shortage uh there's a number
of other Specialties that dentists
there's shortages so it's not just about
getting people
um the coverage and insurance but you've
got to make sure that there are
providers as well but that second part
is mood if people can't afford and don't
have coverage you know
yeah which kind of tells me that it's
actually a two-fold problem that both
need to be solved and what terrifies me
is if we solve just one of those parts
without the other it makes it a really
strong Republican talking point that oh
you have Medicare but you don't have
access
yeah and the thing about it is it's a
strong talking point in different ways
depending on what point you're trying to
make and your perspective but a lot of
this uh is a problem that's actually
been building for a while and there's a
documentary on Netflix I forget the name
of it but it's about rural Tennessee
um and there's places that just like
there's no Dentistry there's no it's
it's it's really crazy
um and uh yeah you're bringing up a very
important issue
and is there um
now that you mentioned shortages of
doctors is there like
education for the people that want to be
doctors yeah so you're saying like are
there enough medical schools right is
sort of the question yep yeah basically
I think so yeah I mean I I believe there
are you know I think part of the problem
is
more doctors exiting and not enough
coming in to replace them so I don't
know that it's an issue of not enough
capacity at medical schools at all
oh it could be not just capacity but
also like is there Opera even if there's
the capacity is there the opportunity
for someone who's low in who's grown up
low income well whoever wants to can can
get loans and then there's a question as
to whether that's prudent and whether
they'll be able to pay them back and in
how long but
um yeah there you poor people can go to
medical school if they get in by taking
out loans the question is does that just
make the student loan crisis even worse
because of what medical school costs
that that's a big big topic but yes it's
possible if you get in to just get loans
and a lot of people think that that's a
bad idea
yeah and honestly points to me to maybe
we should be better subsidizing this
since we need doctors anyway even before
trying to implement Medicare for all
yeah and a great thing I don't know
about before we can do it at the same
time but some of the programs where if
you work in certain underserved areas as
a doctor for a certain number of years
your medical school debt is Forgiven we
need to expand programs like that
I agree with yeah and those programs
exist
oh yeah which you know they just seem
underfunded unfortunately yeah they
could be expanded they could be expanded
but all good good issues good questions
and last thing I'm thinking about in
this kind of area like if you're a
doctor in the middle of New York City
um you might be technically giving
access to the people around you but is
there good ways to address like there
might just be too many people for one
doctor even if you're all technically in
the access area yeah you oh you need
more doctors I mean this is an issue
with primary care doctors
I don't quote me on this but I think on
average a primary care doctor has like
2500 patients in their uh kind of like
docket so to speak and in some places I
think that they even go significantly
higher than that due to demand
um and then this is why now this
concierge medicine thing is coming up
where you pay an annual fee to the
doctor separate from like having
insurance and for visits and the doctors
sometimes have as few as 300 or or
sometimes 600 patients and so you have
much more access and longer appointments
and whatever sort of like what it should
be without having to pay extra you can
now pay for if you want it and you have
the means because it's gotten so crazy
with pcps
ah good old memes uh yeah
so yeah that's uh I say that's what's on
my mind about um just yeah basically
trying to fix the whole American Medical
system it's a big it's a big task uh
good to hear from you Sullivan it's
what's the temperature like in Phoenix
these days
not as bad as you'd think although in
part that's because it's not summer yet
right
um actually it's pretty overcast today
with a chance of rain all right well
let's see what happens with that chance
and I look forward to hearing uh from
you again
and we'll be sure to call in again have
a good one all right Sullivan from
Phoenix Matt says via Super Chat David
you get to interview Trump but only get
two questions what are are they does
your wife really call you sir and why
are you flushing the toilet 10 to 15
times I think that those are the things
I'm most uh most curious about that have
not been asked already let's go to Lucas
from Vermont Lucas from Vermont welcome
to the program
hi can you hear me yes I can okay
um I was wondering what your stance on
transitioning to 14-month calendar is
I've never heard that proposed why would
we do it so um basically what it would
do is um
when uh it would make all months or all
days of the month uh fall on the same
week
oh no matter like what month we're in
and it will make every single month an
equal amount of days so it would like
kind of make it easier for people I
guess
um that's like my main that's really so
in other words with a 14-month calendar
how it was how many days per month would
it be
um I forget I did not see but um all I
know is like the same amount I think
like 30. I'm pretty sure you know the
thing that's not making sense to me
about that
is 365 divided by 14. that's
26.07 and 365 because it's an odd number
it's not going to divide evenly into 14.
you just can see that right away so I
don't know how that would really work
yeah um I've seen some people argue for
it that was like the main
argument I've heard um I just think the
transition might just not be worth it
the transition would be crazy yeah
because then I mean it's just you know
it's an interesting idea but uh there's
a leap year okay all right people are
adding to it I'd have to think through
the math you know
yeah
where in Vermont are you
oh um I'm in Putney it's a small town
I'm going to a college called Landmark
okay yeah I've been through part is
Putney on 89.
um I think so uh it it's uh it's just
like negative 20 here a few weeks ago do
you ever get up to Burlington
I have not been there yet I just moved
here like six months ago oh all right
fair enough all right well listen let me
look into the calendar thing okay okay
all right very good all right there is
Lucas from Vermont oh people are saying
the solar calendar divides the year into
13 months of 28 days uh right but 13
times 28 it's 364. oh and then you have
a leap year with one more oh okay that's
interesting that's not bad I kind of
like that that's pretty interesting I
have to say I want to say thanks to Josh
Barrow who just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code Tick
Tock Feb also want to say thanks to Tiny
sir Jen who just gifted five
subscriptions via twitch putting us at
116. it's incredible
oh Tick Tock by the way
our Tick Tock has exploded it it I don't
even know what's happening we're almost
at 400 000 followers on Tick Tock last
month I think my colleague John told me
we had 32 million views on tick tock
in a month
that's insane so the next thing with
Tick Tock is they have this new creative
fund that we want to be part of so we
can like better monetize our content we
don't make anything on Tick Tock
um and we're gonna keep pushing I've
been doing the live streams and
different things it's really a hell of a
platform for us
um and uh you know a lot of people
saying David it's all Bots it's all Bots
I now get recognized as much from people
who say I watch you on Tick Tock as I do
from people who say I watch you anywhere
else if it were Bots people wouldn't be
coming up to me you know on the street
with tears all down their face
saying I watch you on Tick Tock you know
Ellie McCormick just uh gifted a
membership at joinpakman.com and his new
member number 117 today
let's go to I don't know how about Drew
from New York Drew from New York welcome
to the stream I can hear you fine
awesome okay I have two things um first
off I don't know if you've watched but
the I think it was a few days ago or a
week ago it was the Wisconsin
um Supreme Court
um uh primary which we've had the runoff
I noticed that when you add up the
liberal Justice and the conservative
Justice voice it goes to liberals by
like plus seven I'm wondering if such a
if the primary turnout is is Equitable
at all to the
um what the actual election which
happens in April I have no idea you know
I are you typing right now out of
curiosity
no you're not oh interesting
um I honestly am not sure I have not
followed that uh closely enough to be
able to say but I know a couple people
emailed me about it let me let me look
into that and see
okay the other thing um I noticed about
a month and a half ago you had someone
called in asking about NASCAR which
um I noticed there are two things that
you mentioned mentioned in that there
are a few Northeastern tracks like in
New Hampshire and Pennsylvania but I
also noticed that you said you're
interested as an anthropological
experiment yes
um so my dad has gone to every race that
I've been with I've been to and he said
that every time he goes like NASCAR fans
at the racetrack are the most unhealthy
people he's ever seen unhealthy
physically
yes oh like what do you mean they're
obese
basically yes oh interesting huh uh I
don't know what you make of that
I don't know I thought you might find
that partly interesting it seems it does
seem does seem interesting yeah maybe
someday I'll go to a to a NASCAR race
who knows yeah
um if you're are you on are you like in
the city or something I shouldn't ask I
know the closest track is that would be
Pocono in Pennsylvania there is one in
Upstate New York as you had thought but
it's about twice as far away where is
the where so how far is the Pocono one
from the city
um so I live on Long Island Long Island
obviously um it's it's about two and a
half hours where I am and I think I'm
about 40 minutes away from the city okay
so less than two hour drive to Long
under two hours yeah and then where's
the upstate one
Watkins Glen Watkins Glen okay all right
well listen Maybe someday I'll find
myself in a NASCAR race all righty all
right my friend great to hear from you
thank you for having me all right very
good
uh let's go next to ray gun from
Washington State ray gun welcome back to
the program it's been so long and it's
great to have you here let's see if
raygun will accept actually this might
be the other ray gun either way both ray
guns have been on
and raygun is not even accepting the
invitation to be on so we may never even
find out which one it is interestingly
enough
which would honestly be pretty sad
that should be pretty damn sad ray gun
okay you're on are you there buddy
yes
I can hear you
is it is this me let me guess you're
using like some kind of Bluetooth
well you know what that last guy
I don't care what he says I heard it too
but you're not really are you using
Bluetooth right now
neither here nor there David
yeah
you're a lawyer right you know how to
not answer a question I guess
I want
I want how the baby is doing baby is
doing well
recently
no I mean you know it's it's stunning
when I look at the newborn pictures I'm
like who is that baby it looks nothing
like her
strange
you know how I can tell you know how I
can tell you're on a Bluetooth because
there's a delay you're hearing me on a
delay
no I'm just soaking it all in David when
it's very rare that I get to talk to you
and when I do I just wanna
cherish the moment right hey have a good
day and I enjoy the show and uh enjoy
what you do take care this is it yeah
that's all you got for me
well I did I did want to I had some
other commentary but I I don't know if
you have time well like give me give me
a hint of it and I'll tell you if it's
good
let me ask you this let me ask you this
please
so
all the candidates wanted to go soft on
Trump because they thought that they
could Court
Trump's followers and that Trump would
burn out right right so everyone was
really everyone was really nice even
like Chris Christie who was kind of
known for being an was like
being really conciliatory to Trump
and it was clear that was a strategy and
DeSantis is doing the same thing now
and I don't know that he has a choice
because I don't know if he has the chops
to be a dick yeah
um but it seems like that kind of would
have to be the strategy otherwise you're
just gonna get you know totally cucked
by trump it seems like to me don't you
think yeah I I'm with you and I know
that every time I talk about this people
write to me and they have some kind of
different view on this I uh
I understand why DeSantis isn't just
blasting Trump yet because he's not even
running so it'd be weird to already be
like insulting Trump and going ad
hominem at the same time the guy is so
uncharismatic that I just don't see how
he like I think Trump's going to crush
him if he actually runs if and when a
national campaign gets going and I think
DeSantis isn't well suited to go low and
also going high isn't going to get him
the nomination so it's just not looking
good to me
yeah when I hear the local talk radio
guys talk I mean they like we joke about
the nicknames Trump gives people and
stuff like that because it's kind of
funny but yeah that's what those guys
really care about yeah on the right like
they they're thirsty for the insults and
I think like if you're if you're trying
to do this
you know Trump was a great president and
uh you know what what a nice guy I'm not
going to get down in the in the dirt
with him I just think you're going to
get steamrolled I don't know if there's
a way around it you are listen Reagan I
appreciate you turning off the Bluetooth
that was really kind of you and
um I do think that we're going to be
watching this primary very very closely
yeah more and more people are talking
about it about Bluetooth I know it's
crazy
all right thanks good to hear from you
there's Ray Gunn from Washington
dumping in some knowledge
always great to hear from him why don't
we go next
to Ike from Lagos Ike we tried to make
the connection with Ike earlier
Ike from Lagos is this Legos Nigeria my
friend
uh hello can you hear me yes I can
uh yeah uh yeah uh had a problem with my
microphone earlier but uh yeah it's a
Lagos Nigeria uh I I just want to
believe you are the second I don't know
that you are Nigerian but you're the
second caller from Nigeria that we've
had
uh
well I've actually called earlier before
but oh so you're the same guy no wait
but hold on do you mean earlier today
no no but I've called you before but
that was when I was in uh University in
uh Scotland oh okay all right yeah you
know Fair yeah I am I am Nigerian uh but
I just wanted to call
to uh Wonder wanted to know how much you
you know about our elections going on uh
we had election on Saturday so just
wondering how much I have not been
following it
yeah but uh very interesting actually
because
hi uh this is arguably the tightest
election in our in our history uh
not not that our Democratic history is
that long I mean uh I I know about
Argentinian history and uh
both our countries aside from a love of
football we share a lot with regards to
you know military uh dictatorships uh
controlling our country for a long time
but but this election is actually one of
the the tightest and
I just want to speak a little bit about
it it uh
three candidates basically uh
uh and if you you if you know anything
about Nigeria it's a very diverse
country you know lots of ethnicities
lots of uh different tribes uh basically
split down in half between Muslims and
Christians and so you know you have
three candidates two of them Muslim one
from the north one from the south and
the third one Peter Obi this is the one
that's been making a lot of waves
internationally you may have seen some
reports about him he's he's the
candidate that a lot of younger people
in this country are really taken into
it's almost like a Bernie Sanders if I
had to compare him to like an American
analogue you know he he represents the
labor party he's he's the one that a lot
of of the younger ones have taken to
he's a southern Christian uh of of Igbo
ethnicity I'm also Igbo as well so
a lot of people in my family have been
very very passionate about him and the
results came out
he finished in third place
a lot of people very uh you know they're
doubting the results I don't know I
don't want to sort of compare it to like
uh what you have with Trump where he was
sort of you know refusing to accept the
results but obviously you know
African countries don't really have a
strong tradition of of you know stable
and
um you know clean elections so
possibly you know right now the
international the international people
that came down to help with the
elections they don't really see any
issues with it they think you know there
were problems of course in terms of
coordinating the vote but not not in
terms of outright rigging or anything
yes but yeah I mean it's it's a it's a
very interesting case I mean right now
they're going through they're gonna go
through the process you know of you know
uh
going to the courts and you know seeing
well we are going to follow it all did
you did you have a question for me today
and I ask only because we have so many
people waiting and and we're taking
questions I just I just wanted to to ask
you know how much you knew about it and
very little unfortunately I wish I had
more time to follow more closely in any
number of countries including Nigeria uh
but I will do my research my friend
yeah all right no problem thanks all
right EK from Lagos great Legos great to
hear from you uh very very interesting
country Nigeria and one that I know more
about than many other African countries
I would say but not nearly enough to
speak with facility
about the subject matter
um okay let's uh let's go to
oh I don't know why don't we go to uh
Donut from Virginia Donut from Virginia
welcome to the live stream what's on
your mind today
donut go
you gotta unmute yourself donut your
muted self mute
self mutes are unfortunate you hear me
yes I can
oh so I wanted to ask a question that
what advice do you have for like young
young men in particular who watch your
show
well advice for what and in which
situation I don't have General so I
don't have like a list of 12 things like
Jordan B Peterson
where I would say young men should
clean their rooms you know uh I if you
tell me more about the situation I can
do my best to give advice
you know let me let me actually let me
do it a different way here's what I
would suggest
um get a consistent sleep schedule
uh try to go to bed and wake up at the
same time every day make sure that you
don't get dehydrated try to have at
least 150 minutes a week of aerobic
exercise where you were at least
elevating your heart rate a little bit
uh health status permitting limit the
amount of time that you spend on social
media and consuming news try to schedule
in at least 20 minutes a day to read and
try to get at least five showers a week
that would be my general advice to young
men
yeah thank you that's all I wanted to
ask all right very good there is Donut
from Virginia you know sometimes when I
get calls like that
it's like I start to go well you know
it's like it's very hard to answer that
can you tell me like what's going on or
like what kind of advice are are you
looking for I should just answer the
questions as asked you know like why why
do I have to come in and say the
question doesn't really make sense and a
lot of these people who just give
generic advice to everyone it's it's
really not Taylor I should just give
just give the advice you know what I
mean it's just like it's so much simpler
it's so much simpler
um okay let's go to Nathan from
Melbourne Nathan from Melbourne welcome
to the live stream what is it like 9 15
Thursday morning there
oh God Nathan from Melbourne you've got
to accept the invitation please
hey uh David uh it's about quarter past
11 here
quarter past 11 wait so it's 16 hours
later how is that possible with only 24
time zones I don't even get it
it's uh it's Thursday 11 15. all right
well I believe yeah but it just sounds
odd you know
it is it's very strange
um I actually work my sleep with folks
in the US so I sort of live half my life
on U.S time zones all right fair enough
well what's on your mind today
uh yeah I was just gonna ask about
um do you have any philosophy that you
take to issues of boycotts and
cancellations so I know something that
comes up a lot is often on the left
there's you know a push to boycott folks
that are perhaps uh you know spreading
ideas that aren't particularly
Progressive I'm thinking particularly at
the moment in the media there's a lot of
attention being paid to JK Rowling yep
and like her influence on trans issues
and there's a lot of boycotting of the
Hogwarts Legacy game which has come out
recently yeah
um I don't know what what kind of
philosophy here's my philosophy on
boycotts let's take it in Parts okay
boycotts 100 a form of speech completely
valid as a as a tactic
Beyond reproach people should feel free
and should be confident that they should
be uh uh um allowed to
boycott call for a boycott ask
advertisers to boycott all a hundred
percent fair game okay speech can have
consequences someone says something you
find deplorable you organize a boycott
that's your speech everybody's speaking
free market of ideas
Etc that's statement number one
number two
I do think it's useful to be strategic
when boycotts are used as a tool because
they can backfire when they fail it can
sometimes hurt the cause and sometimes
people can get stuck in sort of like
hypocritical situations or sticky
situations I'll give you one example I
am not a supporter of the boycott Israel
Movement Like personally and there's a
bunch of reasons why I think it actually
often hurts the very Palestinians that
it it that I think some people think it
would help but one of the really
interesting things about it is
it's almost always sort of like uh well
let me boycott some stuff like I'll
boycott uh some of the food products
like I'm not gonna go to Trader Joe's
because they have Israeli feta cheese
it's like okay but when it comes to all
of the medical products all of the
medications and all of the medical
technology
um that comes from Israel well no that's
different that's different that's
totally different
there no no I mean because that's like
because people's lives are at stake and
all right well then so like you don't
really mean it do you like you it's like
when it's convenient you'll skip the
Israeli feta at Trader Joe so you know I
think it's also important to um bear in
mind ways in which it might just not
like function in exactly the right way
and you might end up in kind of a
hypocritical situation but as a tactic
and as a technique in general I have no
problem with boycott as a tool
whatsoever
yeah no that sounds uh that sounds
interesting I agree I think a lot of the
time there's a there's a degree of
pragmatism that often gets lost in
boycott so far and often I can feel that
I agree with the sentiment of what
people are putting out but I can see in
practice in the world it to many degrees
is having the opposite effect to what
they want because it's just motivating
the opposite side because perhaps
they're lacking Nuance in the discussion
or perhaps they're just being a bit too
hard line about certain things so yeah
no appreciate appreciate your thoughts
all right great to hear from you I
appreciate it
have a good one all right let's go to oh
I don't know uh how about
let's go to Alex from Cardiff Wales Alex
from Cardiff Wales welcome what is it
like just past midnight there yeah so
it's 20 past midnight well welcome I'm
gonna be in your neck of the woods soon
not I don't think I'm actually going to
make it to Cardiff but I am going to be
in Southern England maybe sort of like
southwestern ish England
that's where I'm from before University
actually so I actually study here at
Cardiff for University but I'm actually
from like the more southern part of
England
let me ask you then if I had I'm going
to be mostly in London but I'm going to
have about three days to go somewhere in
the south of England I've received
recommendations for Brighton uh
Southampton some of the smaller towns uh
Bournemouth Etc my only requirements are
that once I'm there it's mostly walkable
that there's a pretty good food scene
and that it's relatively close to
Gatwick Airport do you have a strong
feeling of where I should go for three
days
yeah well Southampton is quite good but
uh kind of the city on the other half of
that Portsmouth bit of a rivalry of
Southampton it's got good food
everything's walking distance it's kind
of a small small city with a massive
dockyard I think president Trump's
actually done a speech there
uh so yeah it has to be a very good
place to visit really good culture and
history there so Southampton would be
your choice
sorry yeah over Brighton over Brighton
yeah
um people do tend to like Brighton but I
think it's a bit overrated
um
yeah I'd say Portsmouth good culture
there good history
um got the old Royal Navy dockyards
that's actually worth visiting I will
investigate but let me not take any more
time away from you what's on your mind
today yeah I was just gonna ask kind of
where do you think um or how do you
think America's got to the point where
it's kind of divulged so much from the
rest of kind of European Politics on the
fact that we're quite United here in the
majority of uh modern European countries
were quite uh by for example the UK has
the NHS and lots of other countries like
Germany have nationalized health
services yeah but when I see kind of uh
us on Tick Tock and YouTube it just
seems so radically far right all of it
it seems how they got to this point from
from kind of the rest of the world
politics you know there's no simple
answer to that and the answer really
would be like 10 different things but
I'll give you what I think is one big
difference there is a degree of in
so-called individualism in the United
States that verges on the sociopathic
that I don't see as prevalent at least
not in Western Europe When I visit and I
think that's it's it's I'm not saying
it's the only Factor you know everybody
always wants to say here's the one thing
there's no one thing but the degree to
which the in what people see is
individualism has become completely
weaponized I think is a big factor in
the departure from the the Western
European sort of tradition
of course yeah so yeah I definitely see
that when I'm watching kind of a lot of
people kind of wanting to be unique and
special in the fact of they have their
free speech they have their rights and
they want to kind of exercise them
constantly I think we're kind of more
just chill around here in the rest of
Europe we just we like how it is we're
happy with things don't really want this
extreme change interesting yeah no I and
and there are so many other differences
as well but I do think that that's
that's one big one
that's great well thank you very much
David all right my pleasure there's Alex
from Cardiff Wales with some
recommendations and a lot of very
interesting and important things let's
go to next to Dino from San Francisco
Dino from San Francisco welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
David can you hear me well I can hear
you and well yes
okay perfect
um I have a question about the Russia
and Ukrainian conflict
um
you know during the Iraq War and during
America's large involvements in the
Middle East during the 2000s I grew up
hearing my Dialysis in the Republican
talk radio I grew up hearing Fox News
and the TV a lot
um and a lot of it was
quite frankly islamophobia
fear-mongering about Islamic terrorism
and it seemed that
Republicans and Congress Republicans in
the media were quite United in this
American patriotism and you know
advancing the war in the Middle East and
getting them in Iraq
um
but now we have Russia which is one of
the United States historical Rivals with
the Cold War Legacy and we have people
in Congress like Marjorie Taylor green
Lauren bobert Matt Gates
saying things like not another Penny
will go to we'll go to Ukraine for
Russia if Republicans take over we have
Tucker Carlson running defense for
Russia on Fox News many other hosts on
Fox News running defense for Russia
seeming to belittle Ukraine
me if you would have asked me five years
ago
okay Russia invades Ukraine how does the
right react I think the right could have
galvanized a lot of support
and could have made it a policy decision
of theirs especially with their links to
the defense industry to really support
Ukraine for democracy for the Republic
for patriotism whatever they would try
to spin it but you have so many
conservatives writing defense for Russia
while the left in the media in Congress
by the administration seems to be pretty
United in that
Ukraine should receive some support and
Russia is completely wrong in their
Invasion 100 correct Preamble now dino
did you have a question today
yeah why do you think Republicans are
running so much defense for Russia well
the Dynamics have shifted
um and you can even go back uh you can
go back some ways where the Right
started becoming sort of not immediately
enamored but sort of curious about the
ways of the authoritarians the right
started employing increasingly populist
rhetoric but it was backed with
authoritarian ideas and the natural
reaction when that's the case is you end
up where Maga trumpism ended up which is
basically being most interested in other
authoritarians and that includes erdogan
duterte Putin Kim Jong-un
bolsonaro and so this has been something
that has taken place over a number of
years you're a hundred percent correct
that if you zoom out you would have
thought that Russia invading Ukraine
would have been the perfect opportunity
for Republicans to say we need to go and
spread democracy and make a hell of a
lot of money doing it with our defense
contractors or whatever the case may be
that alignment has changed dramatically
starting a couple years before Donald
Trump took office and accelerated when
Trump took office and you get to where
we are today or or Bond as well Victor
Orban is another one they love
yeah when he spoke Victor Urbana at CPAC
really blew my mind like chilling stuff
do you think it's a miscalculation by
Republicans like I think let's be honest
here for having difficulty winning
elections with you know 2022 midterms
and you know what Paul Ryan was saying
about how Trump keeps losing them
elections yeah I think they could have
galvanized a lot of support if they were
super pro-russia if you put yourself you
know in the mind of a republican Insider
do you think that was a miscalculation
or do they actually gain a lot of
support by you know advancing the
rhetoric and supporting these
authoritarians like you're talking about
I think it's not clear to me that
there's much impact one way or the other
I think the core of the base just Falls
in line with whatever the talking points
are and I don't have any reason right
now to think it's a needle mover one way
or the other to be totally honest
okay very interesting David thank you
for your analysis I watch your show
every day I love it my pleasure Dino
from San Francisco great to hear from
you all right folks that's gonna do it
for CPAC day one there was no CPAC they
seem to have canceled day one tomorrow
is day two I will be back it's going to
be an incredible thing and I look
forward to seeing everybody then thank
you to everybody who signed up and got
memberships and supported in all of
these different ways let's go for two in
a row we'll see everybody tomorrow